okay and then I would like to introduce
our speaker Seton wasanwa
um she is the founder and CEO of
Sentinel a startup that utilizes
patent-pending technology to provide
claims-free coverage for hard to ensure
risks in the areas of interrupted
utilities climate change infectious
disease and event cancellation fentanyl
will first launch with coverage for
extended power outages and has just
finished building out the MVP
prior to founding Sentinel Sato managed
product strategy and Innovation at
Allstate where she defines strategy and
orchestrated collaboration across
Innovation product data science pricing
and marketing teams to develop patented
new to Industry risk assessment products
she also brings extensive experience and
strategy operations marketing and
organizational design from her time at
firms including Bannon Co McMaster Carr
and draft FCB moreover she's
enthusiastic about how distributed
Ledger technology will transform how we
work live and play
the top holds a ba and MBA from the
University of Chicago
okay awesome and then I'll hand that
back over
all right thank you so much for that
warm introduction I really appreciate it
and thank you uh to everyone who's uh
tuning in super excited to share about
Sentinel with you today as well as how
python is helping us live into our
mission to provide that claims free
coverage for hard to ensure risks and
really provide greater peace of mind for
people everywhere all right so I'm going
to start sharing my screen
okay so everybody able to see my screen
right
Perfect all right we'll hop right into
it so um it's been mentioned
um Sentinel uh is a platform uh
parametric platform that provides claims
free coverage for hard to ensure risks
so
um we'll dive into a little bit uh in
just a moment what parametric uh means
so and why uh python was so crucial to
being able to develop Sentinels and VP
and Beyond so for our agenda today it
was going to give a bit of an
introduction on me then dive into you uh
telling you all about Sentinel and then
how Sentinel leverages python what our
next steps are as a startup and then
leaving some time for Q a at the end now
of course if anybody has any pressing
questions is I'm going through this feel
free to put those questions in the chat
um and then otherwise we will address
them at the end
all right so uh beautiful wonderful
introduction from Olivia so I don't
really feel like I need to tell you
anything more about myself she's covered
it all
um but I am the founder and CEO of
Sentinel and um have had the opportunity
to work across a lot of great
organizations in the past and most
recently prior to founding Sentinel I
was managing product strategy uh and
Innovation at Allstate which is uh where
I met um soy Chang
um and we worked not necessarily on the
same projects but within the same uh
department so we'll move it right along
to finding out about Sentinel so
Sentinel provides claims-free parametric
coverage for hard to ensure risks so
I'll start actually on the right so with
traditional Insurance
um when the policy holder experiences a
risk they have to jump through a number
of Hoops in order to potentially uh get
reimbursed on their claim so first the
insurer wants to see did the policy
holder submit a claim and so if they did
then the policy or the insurer is
wondering was the risk actually covered
and then from there what was the
approximate cause of loss and is that
covered so for example you can
experience water damage but not all
water damage is covered um if that water
damage was due to flooding if that's
excluded from your policy it's not going
to be something that you'll be able to
get reimbursed for and so from there you
the insurer wants to know how much
damage occurred and then was the
deductible met and then maybe your
insurer is going to reimburse your claim
so that's kind of like a super high
level
um picture of what the traditional
Insurance experience looks like but if
we turn our attention to the left hand
side of the the screen here we can see a
high level illustration of what a
parametric coverage approach looks like
so with parametric we're simply asking
did the event occur yes or no and if the
event did occur then we're going to send
that payout that we agreed to with a
policyholder at the beginning when they
set up their policy if the event did not
occur
um if those parameters were not met then
there's no payout it's that simple
foreign
at Sentinel is to provide greater peace
of mind that empowers more effective
communities every year we're seeing
a host of risks across interrupted
utilities climate change infectious
disease and event cancellation so with
introverted utilities we're seeing that
four million and more people go without
power for three days or more within the
climate change category 71 of adults in
the U.S indicated that they have
experienced extreme weather within the
past year on the Infectious Disease side
of things each year in the U.S we have
23 million people or more who are
seeking treatment for infections and
then with event cancellation I think
about I I can't get to tell you how many
people I know who had to cancel weddings
or whatnot during the pandemic and then
we can move into things like conferences
I was supposed to go to South by
Southwest for the first time in 2020 and
obviously didn't get to go and do that
so we're seeing hundreds of billions of
dollars are spent on events each year
and much is lost when we have to cancel
those events
Sentinel however aims to make billions
of dollars in hard to ensure risks
coverable
and then by doing this we will reduce
anxiety and complications we'll improve
quality of life and increase
productivity
so our pipeline is filling up with
multi-industry distribution Partners
right now our pipeline for distribution
so by distribution I mean how will we
actually get sentinel's policies into
the hands of would-be policyholders our
potential uh partner list we've signed
agreements to explore Partnerships with
a financial services provider for small
to medium-sized businesses a 30 billion
dollar multinational energy and digital
automation company a developer of
climate resilience energy and energy
efficient homes as well as we're
exploring a partnership with one of the
largest utility providers in the U.S
that serves well over 5 million accounts
so why are they lining up to distribute
coverage for hard to ensure risks
well let's look at the need the majority
of U.S adults need coverage for hard to
ensure risks whether we're talking about
interrupted utilities or an infectious
disease or climate change and event
cancellation we ran a study with over
400 participants and what we found is
that 73 of us adults indicate that they
do not have adequate coverage for these
hard to ensure risks moreover we are
increasingly facing these hard to ensure
risks every year and they're costing
over 500 billion a year in the us alone
traditional Insurance uh on the other
hand can't adequately cover these risks
for a host of reasons including things
like inconvenient claims processes
opaque terms and exclusions and all of
which translate into slow reimbursements
uh processes and a subpar customer
experience I mean when we think back to
your hurricane Ian that occurred last
year
um even though I'm in the industry I've
been in the insurance industry it still
blows my mind that millions of people
once you file claims in the wake of
Hurricane Ian only to discover that
things like windstorms so hurricanes and
tornadoes or flooding is typically
excluded from your standard home or
renters insurance policy
so what are we to do how can we address
these hard to ensure risks the solution
is Sentinels claims free parametric
coverage that addresses these hard to
ensure risks so imagine being able to
receive a hassle-free payment If you
experience any of the risks that we've
got Illustrated here on this page so
with infectious disease for example
imagine being able to take out a policy
that says hey if my lab results show
that I've tested positive for this
particular pathogen and I've been
hospitalized for this amount of time
they don't receive a payout of X with an
introducted utilities which is our
initial use case and we've built our MVP
around this imagine being able to say
hey I live in this County if we
experience the power outage that lasts
more than three days I'd like to receive
a payout of lie under climate change and
weather related events that would be
similar we would be able to say here's a
policy that indicates that if you live
in a particular geography zip code
County and you experience a tornado of a
certain category or flooding to a
certain level you can choose your payout
amount in the wake of such an event and
then finally with event cancellation
we'd be able to tie these different risk
occurrences to specific events in time
so I'm sure you're wondering how does
this work well let's take a closer look
Sentinel provides coverage in six steps
first our platform defines the triggers
and rides that contract so that the
policy holder can complete a short
survey that our platform uses AI to
classify their risk and recommend a
policy
from there once the policyholder has
agreed to those contract terms then our
platform is scanning real-time databases
to ascertain whether a covered risk has
occurred should we detect that a covered
risk has occurred then we automatically
send that pre-agreed upon payout amount
to the policyholder no claims required
to make this a little bit more concrete
here is a glimpse of the MVP application
that we've finished building up all the
high priority functionality for so
essentially you could come to us choose
your coverage level so the size of the
payout that you want to receive put in
the address for which you want to
receive coverage process your payment
for your policy as well as set up your
payout account to automatically be paid
out we've already created the data
pipelines that allow us to monitor for
these risk events in real time so should
we detect them we'll actually notify you
and direct you over to your account so
that you can complete a super short
questionnaire so you can verify that you
have experienced the risk and then get
your payout processing right away
so let's take a little look at our
business model so Sentinel will first
generate income from business
perspective through the sale of these
risk coverage uh premiums or policies
from there as we grow we'll expand into
generating Revenue through two
additional streams licensing our
underlying technology as well as
entering into prediction markets and
derivatives Trading
so we know that people are concerned
we've already seen that the majority of
U.S adults do not have adequate coverage
for these hard to ensure risks but
beyond that we also found that people
want coverage seventy percent of U.S
adults indicate that they are interested
in purchasing coverage and that they're
willing to pay 10 to 100 per month for
500 to 10 000 worth of coverage with
this information we were able to then
begin sizing out on what we'd call the
Market opportunity here
now while we know that the risks that
Sentinel is targeting are not unique or
isolated to just the U.S or North
America these are Global challenges for
our initial launch for entering into the
market we are focusing on the US and so
when we zoom into the U.S we find that
the total Market opportunity for U.S
adults is just around 188 billion that
sounds like a really big number so let's
walk through how we get there so we know
that they're just around 260 million
adults in the U.S when we look at the
percentage who indicate that they're
willing to buy across the four risk
areas as well as the average price that
they indicate that they're willing to
pay per month that's how we can do that
math and get out to that 188 billion
dollar number now of course as a startup
we can't tackle all four of these risk
areas at once and we're not trying to
we're aiming to rather we've chosen the
interrupted utilities risk category as
our starting point our initial use case
uh is within and around providing
coverage for extended power outages
that's what we've built our nvp around
and that's where we plan to launch so we
know that within the past year alone
millions of households and businesses
went without power for over three days
due to catastrophes like just within the
past month or so we saw hundreds of
thousands of people with across Oklahoma
Texas Louisiana and more go without
power for days on end um due to storms
and the heat waves that we're
experiencing uh earlier in this year
with the astrological floods and
blizzard that hit Southern California we
once again also saw over a hundred
thousand people go without power for
many days uh than in December I think we
all kind of were probably gripped by the
news around Christmas time with the
blizzard that hit Buffalo and also left
thousands of people without power and
we've already talked about hurricane Ian
in the wake of which uh well over a
million people went without power for
days on end now
had these people had a policy from
Sentinel at the time they would have
been able to receive an automated Speedy
payout that would help to cover things
like spoiled food perished inventory
alternative temporary housing property
damage and more
now when we focus in on the priority
States for our initial use case what we
see is that we have an 18 billion dollar
opportunity now we chose these eight
priority States based off of demand data
we were looking at things like say
Google AdWords data to see where are
people
the most
strongly and organically searching for
things like coverage for power outage or
power outage insurance
and these are the states that floated to
the top
so where are we in bringing uh this
solution
um to the people who need us most well
we've taken significant steps to
providing peace of mind when Insurance
isn't enough from speaking to well over
500 potential policyholders both on the
consumer side and the commercial side to
building out the MVP for initial use
case acquiring substantial risk data in
order to build out our risk pricing
models filing for non-provisional
patents around not just our approach to
covering risk but also our approach into
entering prediction markets and
derivatives trading and then finally
we've also paved the way to receive
Licensing in all 50 states
all right so that's Sentinel in a
nutshell if you will now how has
Sentinel leveraged python in order to
live into our mission and Achieve our
goals well we needed to develop
Sentinels risk pricing model
to do that we had a few different inputs
we had willingness to pay data we also
had historical power outage data by
counting utility across the United
States going back uh several years and
then we also had data around fixed and
variable expenses that we needed to
account for
all of this data put together we were
talking about well over 10 million rows
of data just with the historical
powerage data alone we needed to clean
and normalize that data we needed to run
calculations and analytical processes on
it we needed to structure it and the
output in a form from which we could
derive the insights that we needed in
order to generate the conclusions that
we needed so up first or at the
beginning we kind of wanted to structure
our approach so understanding our inputs
and our desired Target output if you
will we constructed a methodology for
extracting the insights that we needed
now I know enough to be pretty dangerous
in Excel right that's kind of where I've
lived for much of my career personally
I'm not a data scientist by trade so I
was able to do some testing around the
types of analysis that we would like to
do on the data in Excel and along the
way uh it would take me uh sometimes
half an hour an hour two hours just to
Crunch like one process or one formula
it crashed so many times and that was
basically just trying to get through a
few hundred thousand rows of data right
and I knew I was up against Millions uh
I knew that this was a job that Excel
was just not going to be able to do so
what did I do I turned to data
scientists that we were collaborating
with and said hey can we do this kind of
analysis with python and they said
absolutely yes you can so to build
sentinel's risk pricing model
we leveraged python to be able to do
those things around pulling in the data
from the different sources that we
needed um structuring cleaning it
structuring it normalizing it and then
running the analytical processes that
processes on it that we needed to do in
order to spit out the output that would
allow us to build out our risk pricing
model that covers every County across
the United States
so how else will python help Sentinel
provide greater Peace of Mind well at
least a few different ways here are just
some of the ways in which we'll also be
leveraging Python and are beginning to
do so as well so around data engineering
so as we continue to create data
pipelines cleaning and normalizing that
data to bring in information around all
the different risk categories that we
aim to expand into python will be
critical to that from an AI and machine
learning perspective we'll be using
python as we aim to generate Predictive
Analytics for pricing as well as for
recommending coverage levels and things
like that and then finally for
automation so how can we we're thinking
through how we can continue to leverage
python for interacting with risk data
API is detecting fraud and generating
reports and things like that what's next
so what are our next steps so our next
steps are bringing Sentinel to Market
and really there are three boxes that
we're checking capacity distribution and
products so on the capacity side we're
focused on raising a pool of funds to
ensure that Sentinel can cover payouts
from day one so of course as we hit run
rate the premiums that we're collecting
will be able to support that but you've
got to be ready in case we have to uh
send out payouts right as we're getting
off the ground
um the second is around distribution we
kind of talked about this already we're
already securing those Partnerships to
get Sentinel into the hands of the
policyholders that need us and finally
product as we align on the uh
distribution partners and channels that
we'll be launching with we'll fine-tune
our MVP to best fit those partners and
channels
so we are your Sentinel always on guard
to make billions of dollars in hard to
ensure risks coverable thank you for
listening and I'm happy to answer any
questions that may have Arisen as I've
gotten through this information
great thank you I'm gonna stop recording
right now
thank you